we need to add 7.0 five six to six
hundred and five point seven to five
point six seven now when you're adding
any number you always want to make sure
you line up numbers in the same place
and especially when you're dealing with
decimals the easiest way to do that is
just line up the decimals so let's do
that
so this first number right here is seven
point zero five six this second number
right here is six hundred five point
seven so it'll 605 point seven and then
this last number is five point six seven
five point six seven so now we have
everything lined up everything that's in
the ones place is below or above
everything else in the ones ones place
everything in the tenths place is below
or above everything else in the tenths
place so on and so forth so we can add
so let's add it let's add it so you want
to start off in the smallest place so
you start off here this is the tenths
hundredths thousandths place this is
literally six thousandths and you wanted
to add it to the other thousands there
aren't any other thousands so you can
you give you two ways you could just
bring this six down or you could view
this six hundred five point seven as the
same thing as six hundred five point
seven zero zero you can CH it you can
add as many zeros to the right of this
decimal to the right of the seven as you
want since we're sitting on the right
side of the decimal without changing its
value you can also do it here this five
point six seven you could write it as
five point six seven zero now when you
write it like this and you have six plus
0 plus 0 is 6 and you keep going five
plus zero plus 7 is 12 is 12 you write
the two in the hundredths place and
carry the 1 1 plus 0 plus 7 is 8 plus 6
is 14 right the 4 regroup the one into
the ones place 1 plus 7 is 8 8 plus 5 is
13 plus 5 is 18
this is 18 carry or regroup the 1 1 + 0
is just 1 is just 1 and then finally you
have the 6 in the hundreds place nothing
gets added to it
so you can just bring down that 6 and
it's right there and you don't want to
forget the decimal and so when you add
the numbers you get 618 0.42 six or six
hundred and eighteen and 426 thousands
and we're done